hello everyone and welcome to a game
that was suggested to me many times via
different social media and also via
email it's a game between Andrew Tate
and Pierce Morgan now uh as you guys
know I've been out of commission for the
past few days so I've been going over
emails and uh remarkably this game uh
was suggested the mode so so I checked
it out and uh for those of you who do
not know who Andrew and PSR do do check
them out so you understand the game a
little bit better but uh uh you guys of
course know Emery Tate Andrew is uh
Emery's son and uh he he definitely has
a background in chess and as I
understand it from the interview I only
checked uh a little bit I didn't watch
the entire show as Andrew was on the
Pierce Morgan show twice
um uh Pierce was sort of a a student
Champion as I understand it so he also
has a background in chess so uh it's
always very interesting I mean the the
reason why we suggested so much is as
both of them are fairly famous uh very
famous and um right it's always
interesting to see how the the people
who are so so exposed publicly uh you
know coordinate pieces over the board so
let's check it out and then we're gonna
discuss what happens Andrew with the
white pieces opens with Pawn to D4 that
pierce replies with the D5 we have Pawn
to C4 Andrew goes for the Queen's Gambit
and Pierce declines the Gambit he plays
Spawn to E6 and at this point Andrew
asked appears if he was any good and
Pierce replied that clearly from this
opening uh better than you which uh
doesn't really make all that much sense
this pretty much the most common opening
in chess and every top Grandmaster plays
uh but okay Knight the C3 and now uh
Pierce goes for Knight to C6 and okay
you could play this but it's like the
ninth most popular uh uh opening for for
black I mean the most the ninth most
popular third move for black so it
doesn't really offer that much for black
plus blocking your own C Pawn uh isn't
all that impressive but one thing that I
have to mention is that this wasn't even
even a Blitz game they had five more
minutes until the end of the show and
then Pierce started the clock sort of a
countdown five minutes countdown to see
if they will finish the game in five
minutes or if Andrew can beat Pierce in
five minutes as I understand it but okay
Bishop to F4 a very nice Square for the
bishop Andrew now obviously follows
modern Theory or he just understands
just very well and now there are a
couple of games that reach the
disposition but after Bishop to B4 by
Pierce it is now as of move four that we
have a completely new game and okay E3
going for the London setup Bishop
captures on C3 doubling Tate spawns B
captures and C3 and now uh Pierce could
just continue development with something
like Knight to F6 or maybe B6 Bishop to
B7 but he goes for Queen to H4 which is
uh very weird with with the dark Square
Bishop here able to go to G3 denied
being able to come to F3 The Black Queen
really doesn't have all that much to do
there uh he's probably trying to
psychology data or sort of offering the
C7 pawn and allowing the knights that
maybe come into the game like maybe get
a tempo for free but after examining the
position for a few seconds Tate grabs
the pawn on C7 we have Knight to F6 and
now he just brings the bishop back
Bishop to G3 he says thank you for the
Free Pawn and now Queen to G5 and with
the Knight blocking the Queen's Escape
you can see that this queen does not
belong here if the bishop comes to E2
the bishop comes to F4 it's gonna be
very hard for this queen to remain here
but even weirder things happen in this
game Knight to F3 by Tate and now uh
Tate started uh telling Pierce some
story about a yacht in Dubai and I guess
Piers just wanted to uh
play faster moves and he just castled
here leaving his Queen completely
undefended entity just grabbed it at
which point Pierce screamed as he
couldn't believe what just happened uh
and the Tate uh was he was just acting
like everything was perfectly normal he
was telling him a nice story peers
didn't want to listen and then he just
blundered the queen but okay he still
has to beat him before the time on the
clock runs out to Rook to E8 we have
Queen to C2 if the Knight moves there
could be some checkmating ideas here H6
kicking away the Knight Knight F3 and
now but Knight to G4 Andrew just kicks
the night away you don't really have to
do this the Knight doesn't really do
anything here but it's better to kick it
away Knight to F6 and now Bishop to E5
threatening to mess up Black's Pawn
structure so Knight captures an E5
Knight captures and D captures and C4
with Bishop captures and now B6
preparing to feel the the light Square
Bishop black has no counter play here
this game is over it's only a matter of
whether Andrew can finish this game in
time we have castles and now G6 uh sort
of giving Andrew a Target and he
immediately goes for it and
interestingly he played this fairly
quickly and it is the top move
recommended by the engine so he
definitely knows his tactics Knight
captures and G6 point being that after
the queen recaptures both the Knight and
pawn will hang with checks so Pierce
declines this he goes Bishop to B7 and
now Rook a to E1 with ideas of just
pushing pawns or maybe he just wants to
get the Deep one of the board play
rookie 3 Rook G3 and get a checkmating
attack against the black king F
characters on G6 appears does go for
this queen captures on G6 and King to f8
now we have Queen captures and H6 not
grabbing the Knight sort of allowing the
king to defend the Knight but not really
King E7 Queen G7 checking to d8 and now
Queen captures an F6 with check with
Rook the E7 and now Bishop captures and
E6 and at this point there was around a
minute left on the clock uh and if
Pierce wanted to he could actually bleed
out the time he he could just wait and
you know the show would be over but he
played very very quickly so that is a
very nice of him Rook to C8 he develops
but you know the show of just captures
it King captures and see it Queen
captures an E7 and now Bishop to D5 and
Here Andrew has to make some sort of uh
an attack he he has to get those Rooks
into the game or get those Pawns of the
board in order to Checkmate the black
king because he's running very low on
time and he starts advancing the E Pawn
E4 with Bishop to C4 and now Queen to E8
with check he wants to perfectly set up
the black king for a checkmating attack
King to C7 Queen E5 check and now King
to D7 not the greatest of squares
because D5 D6 is coming but whatever
black plays of course black is lost the
five King to d8 D6 and here at this
point Andrew already announced mating 2
because you really can't defend this you
could start running away with the King
then it's made in three but okay that
appears wanted to go out with the bank
he captured The Rook on F1 and now comes
Queen E7 checking to C8 and queen to C7
with checkmate
so a a fun game and a fun choice of
opening but if I had to really even even
without blundering the queen already
here after this uh unfortunate castling
move uh Andrew played pretty much every
move uh a top engine move that like
there was there was no uh bad moves uh
from White and okay black didn't really
allow whites to make a bad move as none
of the black moves were very threatening
uh but every time a white had to make
some sort of an active decision he made
the correct one from grabbing the the
free C Pawn allowing the queen into the
game pretty much everything from there
was uh perfectly played even after after
black blundering the Queen White
finished the game fairly quickly so
interestingly he asked Andrew after the
game uh What uh what his father say
about about his accomplishments in life
he said that he would be very
underwhelmed as his father expected that
of him so uh something uh I found very
interesting and are also really kudos to
Pierce Morgan for not bleeding the clock
like he as they didn't play they didn't
each have five minutes on the clock that
it was just five minutes until the end
of the show and he could have uh like
bleed the time out and claimed that okay
the game didn't end until until the end
of the show or so maybe they call it the
draw but no he accepted his defeat and
um uh uh you know went down went down
like a gentleman uh now I I assume uh as
this is the the the second time he had
Andrew on the show uh first time uh his
his audience wasn't really all that
happy with how he handled the interview
he invited him for the second time and
then he also uh brought a chess set to
finish the uh the show with uh with a
game of chess and it didn't really work
out all that well for him if he was uh
some sort of a champion when he when he
went to school some of the moves were
very very questionable as you guys were
wondering about that but okay now you
have the the breakdown of the game and
you know what actually happened
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it if you have any other such
fun suggestions do use hashtag
suggestion and I will uh go over it I
would like to thank Tom console of
Bradley Campbell constantinos Lamprey
this Jeffrey Clayman and Miller
schnezzrich for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day